there are some breathless reports being
published that say that North Korean
leader Kim jong-un has agreed to meet
Donald Trump at the DMZ
which is the Demilitarized Zone right at
the border between North and South Korea
on the Korean Peninsula and much like
other North korea-related news it's
being reported as if this is some major
unbelievable development but wasn't it
always sort of obvious that that's where
Kim jong-un would want to meet Donald
Trump more than likely we talked at the
very beginning of the sort of
possibility of the summit taking place
about how Kim jong-un said that he's
willing to meet with president Trump as
if it was big news North Korean leaders
have been desperate to get in the same
room as American presidents in order to
elevate their perceived status going
back a very very long time it wasn't
news and along the same lines this time
the notion that it's big news that Kim
jong-un would be willing to have the
meeting at the DMZ really isn't news and
Trump has been tweeting about this
yesterday he tweeted numerous countries
are being considered for the meeting but
would peace house slash Freedom House on
the border of North and South Korea be a
more representative important and
lasting site than a third party country
just asking the other idea was Singapore
Singapore is a place that might not be
obvious why you would have the meeting
in Singapore but Singapore is a place
where the American military has a
presence but there's also a diplomatic
relationship between Singapore and North
Korea as well as a North Korean embassy
so it's one of a sort of smaller subsets
of places that would meet both of those
requirements but from a logistics
perspective it's pretty logical for Kim
jong-un to want to meet at the DMZ right
it allows his team to get set up for the
meeting without dealing with the
possible diplomatic guess we can call
them complexities of traveling around
the world to different places where the
relationship with North Korea may not be
quite so good but really it's the PR and
the propaganda value here combined with
Kim Jong Un's
maybe paranoia that someone might try to
do something to him if he went somewhere
else that immediately pointed to the DMZ
is the place where Kim jong-un would
want to meet and that's the thing about
a meeting at the DMZ because it makes it
so that whatever comes out of the
meeting
getting Donald Trump they're getting him
maybe to step over the line from south
to north korea and shake hands with kim
jonghwan the propaganda value the
self-aggrandizing value of that for Kim
jong-un is absolutely huge and quite
frankly it's huge for Trump as well
right
Trump would love to have video of
himself doing this going to the DMZ
stepping over the line
shaking can't hands with Kim jong-un
regardless of what actually is even
agreed to in principle at the meeting
and regardless of what actually happens
longer term which we've talked about no
matter what's agreed to at the meeting
we actually have to see what the
follow-through is because there's a long
history of talk and no real action or
not the action that we're hoping for
that would be huge for Trump as well and
not that this is my primary concern
would the Secret Service be okay with a
meeting at the DMZ I mean they'd like to
get in clear the entire surrounding area
from where the president will be as far
as we know it's hard to imagine came
jong-un saying Secret Service sure come
into the North Korean side and control
access to the border area how do they
prevent for example I don't know a North
Korean sniper from having a clear view
of Trump during this meeting so
obviously there's no doubt that trying
to kill the president if you're North
Korea would be immediate suicide I'm not
saying they would do it but I'm
explaining why security concerns for
Secret Service would be significant in
terms of a meeting at the DMZ but the
fact that we're talking about a meeting
between an American president and a
North Korean leader at the DMZ
is already huge that I think is really
the most important thing we talked
yesterday how much credit does Trump
deserve we're not going to rehash that
today and I think a lot of that will
sort of be known in retrospect but I am
actually finding to do this to be one of
the most interesting geopolitical
stories and I'm not
it's not a value judgment of Trump in a
way regardless this is going to be a
fascinating month do you think that this
could get Donald Trump the Nobel Peace
Prize trumpets are talking about that
even the South Korean president is
talking about that it's the interesting
idea to float but I don't know we'll
have to see
it's funny how trumpets are all about
America first and only our opinion
matters until South Korea now thinks
that Trump is responsible for the
progress that's been made and we know
that South Korea is one of in the in the
entire world is one of the most Pro
Trump countries and I would wait until
we have more information before jumping
in with South Korea on that I think I
would also wait on the Nobel Peace Prize
I think again it would depend on what is
Trump's actual involvement and
responsibility here which we don't know
well after the Camp David Accords Bagan
and Sadat shared the Nobel Peace Prize
Jimmy Carter didn't get it so if there's
any precedent there that you could read
from that I don't think Donald Trump
stands to be right it would be I guess I
mean Kim jong-un jong-un with a Nobel
Peace Prize will Trump do a classic
handshake power move like he's done with
others and physically pull Kim jong-un
over to the South Korean side then all
of a sudden North Korean soldiers will
grab Kim Jong Un's ankles and pull him
back into North Korean territory that
would be some great video so the month
of May is going to be crazy I'm glad we
have no vacations scheduled in May
other than Memorial Day weekend and a
three week break starting next week so
other than that we'll be here the entire
time no I'm kidding we actually will be
here and covering the summit and
everything else that comes from it the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership